longtime executive in the national
football league now one of the best in
our business talking sports since
talking the nfl
on television from cbs sports amy trask
how are you amy trask i am well and let
me add my thanks for the ongoing
exchange of looney tunes
or gifts i never know if it's a gif or a
gift but whatever it is i love when
michael looney tunes me okay very good
very good terrific um so let's let's
just uh jump right into it uh amy your
first thought when you saw the emails
involving
john gruden and then the stories that
came out that caused him to resign were
what were what
for you boy just an overwhelming number
of thoughts it wasn't one specific
thought um that which was expressed in
those emails was of course horrific and
i you know i love alliteration so i
tweeted out horrific heinous horrible
uh
but it was also not lost on me that the
news first broke on the anniversary of
al's death
and that was very poignant as well given
all that he has done or had done all
that he did in his life
so those are some of the thoughts that
overwhelmed me when the news broke
so
did uh gruden ever give any indication
that you know uh
internally when you were around him that
he had feelings like this towards a
large cross-section of americans and
american life amy trask uh
not in my presence and i will you know
many people assume that given my role in
the organization at the time and given
that he was our head coach that we had a
lot of interaction and i really
appreciate rich that you're giving me
the opportunity
to share a little bit about that i did
not interact with john a lot when he was
a head coach and by a lot i mean not a
lot i mean barely at all and there are a
number of reasons for that and the only
reason i share that is not to try to
distance myself from him at all look he
was our head coach and i was an
executive team but we didn't interact
very much when john first joined the
raiders his primary point of
interaction was of course al but even
that changed over time and his primary
point his
the person with whom he interacted um
the predominant amount of the time was
bruce allen but i will make very clear
that he did not make any comments of
that nature in front of me or in my
presence or in my ear shot and if he did
i would not have remained silent no i
know that
that that i know for that i know for
sure and uh i mean for
sorry go ahead as you can see the reason
i want to note that is silence is
complicity
i agree i i you know and that's why i'm
you know i'm i'm i'm saying what i'm
saying in the microphone what i said
about gruden and how his position became
untenable in the national football
league and to be honest with you you
know and i uh he was always nice to me
um and always great to our network um
bruce allen uh receiving these emails
and uh
you know him as well i i'm i'm
i don't know maybe you call me naive or
the fact that i'm not someone of color
or i am somebody that people is nice to
to their face that i'm kind of i'm
shocked about all this the whole thing
soup to nuts
a couple thoughts in that regard
one only sends
an email of that nature or of you know
many natures
to a recipient that one knows will be
comfortable receiving it or will be
accepting or will agree or will
certainly not be discomforted or you
know you're not sending an email
in which you express
many thoughts not only thoughts of that
nature but many horrible thoughts to
someone unless you know that the
recipient is going to be fine with you
sending that and i'm i'm stumbling over
my words because i'm having a hard time
expressing that which i want to express
so let me just try once more which is
you're only going to send an email or
emails of that nature to someone who you
know is a welcome recipient and i
understand it was not only bruce but
there was a chain and there were some
other people on it as well but you're
not putting anything in an email and
sending it to anyone that you know is
not going to be comfortable with those
emails or welcome them
you got to know that ahead of time but i
will also note that there's a lot of
focus on
wow it was in an email it was in an
email and i understand that's why we
know of this but more concerning than it
being in an email is that it was in his
heart and in his mind i mean let's focus
on the fact that this is what he thought
and this is what he believed and yes it
was in an email and yes it was in a
group email
but this is what he believed
long time raiders executive now cbs
sports analyst
amy trask here on the rich eisen show
so let's get into that too amy you know
the league as well as you do
i mean is this
this is this a prevailing
uh concept women shouldn't be refs
gay people shouldn't be football players
uh uh
players of color shouldn't uh express
themselves on the subject matter of
social justice
during the game uh or prior to the game
i mean
and the anthem i mean is that is this
still a prevailing
concept do you think within the halls of
power of the nfl amy does everyone
believe that does everyone feel that way
absolutely positively not
do many people believe that
i don't know how to quantify many but do
a significant number believe that the
answer is probably yes we certainly know
that some number of people believe that
i don't know how many believe that but i
don't believe it's negligible but does
everyone in the league believe that
absolutely positively not and you know
it's not just a league problem and i
know you know this rich
this is an issue for the nfl but this is
an issue for society as a whole this is
an issue for the country as a whole and
the world as a whole there are too many
people worldwide
that still have those views
and and for for whom words don't really
matter that that that what gruden said
was you know just words in an email
and actions uh have been worse
by others who are allowed to play in the
nfl i mean that's that's what you hear
about but these words in my estimation
considerably matter when you're the head
coach of a team in the nfl you're one of
32
and also you are somebody on a 10-year
contract in the middle of all this so if
you don't mind i'd like to dive into you
know uh the son of your
former boss and and mark davis and what
you think
um he did once he found out about these
emails i mean gruden coached sunday amy
what do you think happened there
i don't know the answer to that i mean
to state the obvious i don't know the
answer um it did raise my eyebrows that
the organization was aware of the emails
as of last friday by the way if not
before because of course we know that
they were disclosed in a pleading filed
in court so they were a public document
i don't know if that pleading was behind
or under seal
um but at a minimum they learned of it
the friday before the monday on which
this was ultimately determined that he
would no longer coach the team
and that decision was made after the
emails became public so it does raise
the question
what if anything might the team have
done or would the team have done had the
emails not become public
i don't know the answer to that
but it did raise an eyebrow
so we're i'll ask you this too amy trask
here on the rich island show i mean
again you're the perfect guest to have
on here you you know the league so well
and the machinations that may be
happening
the question of why
now where did these emails come from and
who leaked it and what possible reason
could there be do you have any
supposition
get best guess theory on all of this
i don't know who leaked them
i have not from the outset assumed that
which many did which was that the league
leaked them and in fact i will share a
conversation with you right now because
this is just you and me right
a conversation that my husband and i had
over ice cream in the kitchen discussing
this when it all came uh public and the
um
everybody was tweeting out and speaking
and writing and sharing the league has
leaked these the league has leaked these
and i looked at my husband and said i'm
not buying that it was necessarily the
league who leaked these everybody's
assuming it was the league who leaked
these i don't assume it was the league
and
that was my view not simply because i'm
a contrarian which you know i am but
because there's a lot of people who
could possibly have disclosed this now
we have learned that it was disclosed in
a pleading and even though there was
some effort to redact names either that
effort failed by accident or on purpose
because not everything was redacted but
there's any number of people who could
have dribbled this out for any number of
reasons and i'm not going to speculate
because remember i'm the girl who went
to law school so i hear ringing in my
head objection your honor calls for a
hypothetical calls for speculation um
but i i haven't bought from the
beginning that it was necessarily the
leak so yeah because
and again this is all began because it
was there is an investigation into
the team that was employing bruce allen
at the time which was not the raiders it
was the washington football team and
there's 600 some odd thousand emails
that uh a lot of people would still like
to see do you think we're ever going to
see
those emails amy trask what do you think
i don't you know to state the obvious i
don't know the answer um if you were to
ask me aim 50 50 chance we see the
emails take the over or the under i
would take the under on a 50 50 chance
doesn't mean we won't see them doesn't
mean we won't see some of them
you know there have been multiple
requests to see them from the nflpa from
the lawyers representing the women in
the lawsuit against the washington
football team so you know might we see
them
yes but again if if pushed to say if i
think there's more or less than a 50
chance i'd go less
so what do you think happens from here
amy what do you think happens now that
this is all out john gruden is out his
name's off the ring of honor in tampa i
mean that a a a quick dissent is not
even
an accurate description as to what has
happened with john gruden and the nfl
his career as a football coach and
certainly somebody associated with the
nfl uh is over um so where do you think
this hat goes from here in your estate i
hope it goes someplace rich and i mean
that in the following regard
we have a as a collective society not
everybody because this is a
generalization but sort of societally we
move on from one story to the next so
quickly there's a huge breaking story
you know breaking news breaking news
whatever the news may be and three days
later or two days or five days whatever
it is everyone has moved on to the next
story and it still stuns me
that we collectively as a society move
on from things so quickly this is not
something from which we should move on
quickly this is a moment from which
everybody can learn and we can all work
to get better because there is a big
problem in this country and in this
world and it is not limited to the nfl
we need to work together to find a way
to fix these issues and moving on from
this story too quickly is not a good
idea well what about more women and more
people of color uh in positions of power
within the halls of the nfl amy how
about that idea i mean in in all
seriousness i mean
that that there should be some sort of
representation uh on on all fronts and i
know some people might roll their eyes
if they're hearing me say something like
that out loud or if they see it later on
on social media
but uh uh honestly the idea i i'm sure
you're out i'm outraged to hear well
women can't ref and what i mean how
stupid is that what are you what are you
talking about and and and and the whole
idea of
uh of players should not speak their
minds on the issue of social justice
utilizing the platforms that they have
i mean it's not like that they stopped
in the middle of a five-yard run and
then took a knee you know what i'm
saying like it's it's
i i
how about that as a as an immediate
response
i i it's tremendous rich and and i got
goosebumps as i was listening to you say
it and i will respond in two regards
um while i agree with the points you
will make i will note that i was smiling
in one regard as you were making them
because i have seen evolution in the
league since i first joined now i know
that a lot of the people who watch your
show who follow you on multiple
platforms weren't even born when i
started my career and yes it pains me to
say that
but when i started in the league i was
the only woman in the room or i should
say the only woman not married to a team
owner or the daughter of a team owner i
was the only woman in the room
that was a long time ago and by the way
credit to al davis for hiring a girl so
many years ago but my point is we have
seen growth
in those years we do see now more women
and some teens to their credit are
putting in place pipelines because you
don't just wake up one day and say i
want to be a ceo or i want to be a
general manager or i want to be a head
coach you need to start at the bottom
and work your way up so i'm glad to see
teams
like the rams like the 49ers and yes
there's more teams but i'm in california
so i'm pointing to some california teams
right start those pipelines so that's
point one but my most important point in
response to what you said is every
single business
everyone and you know what if someone
wants to come at me and say amy that's a
sweeping generalization then come at me
because i'm going to stand by it every
business and any business and each and
every business is better
and stronger when it includes people of
every single ilk and every single
viewpoint
get a room full of people who disagree
with one another who agree to disagree
who challenge one another make sure that
your employee base is diverse be
inclusive because you know what you're
going to be a better business
so let's wrap up with the personal amy
what would you tell mark davis who i'm
sure you've known for a very very long
time what would you tell him i mean that
one um
and i'll i'll pontificate as well in
setting you up that that one-line
statement of saying i've accepted his
resignation i mean that that's not even
remotely close to uh enough
so what would you counsel him to do uh
on on speaking about it and then of
course
cleaning it up and figuring out what to
do next what would you counsel him
well i'll answer that in two regards i
give mark the benefit of the doubt that
he would not have hired john
had he known of these emails
but he did hire john and later learned
of these emails
and he does now need to address that
strongly and unequivocally and the other
thing i would encourage him to do is to
reach out to the raider fan base i mean
so you know period full stop he needs to
he needs to address it and he needs to
address it strongly and clearly
period full stop now i will go on and
say he also needs to reach out
and embrace the raider fan base and
thank them for their ongoing support
look as we know last year allegiant
stadium opened but no fans were allowed
so this is the first season in which
those magnificent fans are allowed in
the stadium and the team was off to a
good start until it stumbled a bit and
then this and that fan base has stood
with that team through thick and thin
and i think he needs to
address the issues substantively and
embrace the fan base and then lastly uh
again this is uh the raider organization
that uh is front and center and the
email was a former raider coach who was
a highly successful broadcaster at the
time sending it to a former raider
executive who is now on another team
and what was in that email that as we
already mentioned in this conversation
amy trask
was uh written by somebody who felt
comfortable writing it and felt
comfortable hitting send to the person
who he felt comfortable
would feel comfortable receiving it
um and those are all raiders all of them
and this is the raiders organization and
his son
[Music]
at the front and center of all this what
would al davis be thinking right now amy
trask you know i've been asked that a
lot rich and as a general rule i try not
to answer questions for al because i can
hear his voice ringing in my ear as to
what he would say if he knew i was
answering questions for him and i can't
repeat on air what he would be saying to
me because i don't want to get you in
trouble
but i will say this yes he would have
been infuriated
by those emails um sickened by them
heart sick
i don't i mean he would have been heart
sick but he would have been infuriated i
won't project i won't say what i think
he would have done i can tell you he and
i would have discussed it at length and
i can i can tell you that no matter what
language i could use with you on air
right now to describe his reaction his
language would have been stronger
i mean he hired you amy i mean
you put a a a female in the position
that he put you in and he put archel in
the position that he put in him in and
was the first to do it and this is the
organization that is
front and center of these conversations
uh i i i
it boggles it really does amy you know
um and and by the way i'll add tom
flores and so of course chronologically
not in order of importance i'd be the
last but chronologically tom flores amy
trask art shell
and look going back to when he hired me
can you name another nfl team owner who
in the midnight in mid 80s would have
hired a girl
it's just it does boggle um and again
i'll i'll say what i believe i said at
the beginning which is the fact that
this story broke on the anniversary of
his death is particularly poignant
amy i appreciate the time um you know
i'll i'll have you on whenever i i hope
that another story like this doesn't
break to you know cause me to reach out
and have you on again but let's do it
again very soon well you better you
better watch what you say because i may
just zoom down there and camp out in
your lobby and just kind of be be there
you got it might not get rid of it you
got it by the way that sounded like one
of the greatest clue games ever with my
husband in the kitchen eating ice cream
that sounded like that that was that was
outstanding that was outstanding that
was outstanding but thankfully there was
a it was just ice cream meeting that's
all it was no crime was committed in
that clue game thanks for the call amy
you're the best
all right back at you that's amy trask
follower uh at amytrask on twitter hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here